quelle belle époque on est en plein dans
la 4e révolue
l'industriel là qui vous
peu un petit peu
on voyait remettre au clair on va
reprendre les livres d'histoire c'est
pas si loin pour vous et la première
révolution industrielle c'était la
machine à vapeur avec le charbon
donc on a commencé à mécaniser
l'agriculture le transport de longues
distances et la deuxième avec la
découverte de nouvelles énergies et
l'électricité le pétrole ça a apporté un
grand nombre de choses nos troisièmes il
ya eu les nouvelles d'une nouvelle
technologie avec l'électro mécanique
l'électronique l'automatisation on a
commencé à produire en masse et à
consommer en masse et là ça fait une
petite dizaine d'années qui a la
quatrième révolution industrielle que
j'aime appeler industrie 4.0 qu on m
appelle dans le milieu industrie 4.0
dont lui donne aux siens un autre nom
c'est la transformation digitale
qu'est ce que c'est un exemple qui va
vous parler à tous les smartphones la
transformation jeu digital c'est
l'interconnexion des objets c'est une
très grande capacité de calcul les
capacités de stockage extraordinaire m à
porter n'importe quel outil de à portée
de main donc cette industrie 4.0 l est
elle est là elle arrive elle est là
depuis dix ans elle se elle continue
alors quand on travaille pas dans ce
milieu c'est compliqué de l'appréhender
moi c'est mon métier depuis un peu plus
d'un an je suis en charge de transformer
les industries vers le cette industrie
4.0 donc quand on connaît pas
c'est délicat de l'appréhender mais je
vais vous donner d'autres exemples
aujourd'hui vous voulez réserver un taxi
un avion un hôtel où tu sais que vous
utilisez quoi le smartphone vous voulez
payer aujourd'hui vous utilisez votre
marceau ou votre smartphone mais
cartésienne et cartes de crédit sans
contact
c'est déjà dépassé l'autre jour j'ai
réservé un vol pour aller à paris
je ressens un mètre de validation et hop
d'un coup ça apparaît dans mon agenda
google on est ultra surveillé et il ya
une extrême interconnexion des systèmes
il ya aussi un gros thème de cette
industrie 4.0 qui est le partage
d'informations tout le monde se sert de
réseaux sociaux je pense ici où on est
en train de prendre en photo son jambon
purée qu'on a mangé à midi pour le
mettre sur le réseau social
donc où est la propriété de
l'information où est la propriété de la
vie privée comment on va gérer cette vie
privée à l'avenir
ça va être très compliqué il ya
également d'autres points qui sont
l'intelligence artificielle par exemple
alors la niche de l'intelligence
artificielle ia ok google et alexa qu'on
connaît un peu tous il ya des choses
beaucoup plus poussée qui sont pas
encore disponibles sur le marché
mais quand vous allez par exemple sur un
site internet pour voir une perte de
cheveux une paire de chaussures même
semble même sans l'acheter vous
retournez ensuite sur un réseau social
et vous voyez dans le bandeau à droite
une pub avec les chaussures que vous
venez de regarder ça c'est déjà
l'intelligence artificielle donc comment
redéfinir l'homme si une machine peut
être aussi intelligente que l'homme
l'homme qu'est ce qu'il définit c'est un
être avec une intelligence supérieure
aujourd'hui un ordinateur bah ça devient
un homme quoi voilà donc cette industrie
4.0 on est ultra surveillée on est ultra
connecté avec mon téléphone je peux
prendre le contrôle de votre voiture je
peux savoir où vous êtes à l'instant t
je reviens sur la phrase du début quelle
belle époque non merci à tous
[Applaudissements]